M if you were saying something before or
in advance about one of the two girls
having a beef with men or some
grievances or something what was that oh
well I think that was the next step like
for Rachel I think she's realizing now
in being in the dating market and we had
a couple quips back and forth that she's
had some I think less than positive
interactions in dating with men over the
last I guess eight months I mean how how
long Rael would you say you've been like
back out there I mean I'm sure that you
didn't immediately just or maybe you did
I don't know did you just download the
apps and just go nuts like what was the
next step um I think I I stayed off the
apps for probably like two weeks but I
think when you're used to living with
somebody and being with somebody
constantly you get lonely very quick um
so honestly it was just nice to have
people to talk to in the beginning um
but the dating world is
trash um I also I'm like I'm too old for
the games dating is not fun to me I'm
like looking for my person not rushing
it but I also don't have time for guys
that just want to sleep around or you
know do that kind of thing so what like
I mean I hear from a lot of guys about
the struggles they have you know dating
and you know the bad luck they have and
the ghosting and everything that sort of
like comes along with that um somebody
in the chat just said welcome to the
club um
what's what are the main problems
problems that you're see seeing out
there you know the know that you're
actually experiencing yourself as a
newly single gal that's looking for a a
serious guy I think a lot of problems
now I've had Tinder when it first came
out and it first came out when I had
just turned
18 um so I had it for a while 10 years
yeah okay um Tinder came out in 2013
yeah it was mostly a hookup app at that
time it still is for the most part yes
um I think that like when I first
downloaded it way back in the day a lot
of people were using it yes to hook up
and that was about it but now I've
noticed that um mind you me and my
fiance we actually met off
Tinder
so um now that I've redownloaded again I
noticed a lot lot of
guys I feel like they just want someone
to stroke their ego like they just want
to
be on there to see what girls they're
going to match with not carry on a
conversation at all get your Snapchat
and be your penp pal for six months and
never even plan on meeting
you that's
interesting
um get your Snapchat and then be your
pen
like how much is that that how much of
that do you think is guys just awkward
anxious socially uncalibrated to the
point where it's like they get a match
they get a conversation but they don't
know how to ask somebody
out um I mean I'm sure it could be that
but I feel like because I mean you're
not gonna ask them out you're not gonna
say he about you know we go grab a drink
right oh I totally would oh you would
yes so why wouldn't you just ask them
out then if you dig the rug
I do and they play games they just are
like oh well I'm free this day and then
the plans don't meet
up and I think a lot of people have
issues with um how much you work too if
you work a lot like I work 13 hour days
every single day um so it's hard for me
13 hour day seven days a week yes what
do you do I work for
infinti Infinity the car company yes
okay so what do you do there I'm a
service advisor so I tell people what's
wrong with their
car 13-hour days are long days like are
is is a service department open on the
weekends on Saturdays and Sundays too
yes it is yeah because they're not open
here on the weekends so those are some
long ass hours yeah it depends on like
what county you're in but they they are
open on weekends depending on the county
that you're in okay so is it is it a
scheduling issue like you can't
coordinate a like a day of the week that
works for you when you're not working
the 13 hour day seven days a
week it's I find that since I have been
because I'll tell you like you know from
the point of a guy like if your
availability is so scarce because you're
prioritizing working at Infinity dealing
with people's car issues over because I
mean you say that you're looking for
something serious right like you want a
serious guy you want to develop
something further you know you want to
move to the next level sort of thing um
working a lot of hours is a bit of a
turnoff for quite a few guys right
because I mean your availability is not
there right so if the guy's like hey you
know I'm available uh Tuesday at this
time to grab a drink and you're like
well I get off at this time so that
doesn't
work yeah yeah like when do you sleep I
mean that's nuts when do you do anything
aside from just work I mean hour days
because you got you got to eat you got
to do some you laundry and a few other
things in between all
that my man works like 14 hours a day so
I get it it's your guy works 14 hours a
day yeah but I mean you guys are
together you've got a kid together you
guys are like get going somewhere no I'm
saying that's what I'm saying I get it
yeah that's crazy yeah but I mean like
from the dating you know angle if you
meet a guy or you're talking to guys of
dating apps and your availability is so
limited cuz
you're I mean you know 13-hour days
you're talking like what does this
service department open at 8 and closes
at 8 or 9ine uh no I'm there at six
o'clock in the morning I wake up at 400
a.m. and I'm there till 7 o'clock
tonight is when I left okay and then
like you're probably cooked by 9 10 11
o'clock like you know you got a crash if
you're getting up at 4 5 o'clock in the
morning right yeah I usually go to bed
at 9 or 10 right so you don't have much
it's like okay you know I have time for
dates at
8:00 yeah or maybe like right after work
still in your service GE right yeah it's
hard during the week um I usually tell
people weekends are best for me um
sometimes my job is pretty lenient like
they'll be like okay well if you want to
leave early that's cool um but most of
the time you know I think with I'm
looking for someone who's On My Level
and I want does that mean on your level
like I want someone who has a drive and
wants
to add to my life and I add to theirs
okay not be in competition or them still
living at their parents house not that
there's anything wrong with that but you
have to have a drive in order to do
things I mean that's just can I just
stop for a sec with all that stuff and I
want to come back to all because I love
this part of the conversation but one of
the things I've noticed with a lady when
we do these ladies night shows it's like
you're so reluctant
to disparage and call stuff out publicly
on a show but on private conversations
on social media you'll just and you know
when I say you I'm not talking about you
specifically Rachel I'm just talking
about women in general they'll just [__]
on guys hard right so when you say that
if the guy lives at home not that
there's anything wrong with that there's
something definitely wrong with that
right like if you're 28 and you're
living at home with Mommy and Daddy and
mommy's still folding your laundry and
you know making all of your meals women
have a problem with that can we at least
be honest with
that I think it depends on what's going
on in your
life how so can we can we get some
elaboration on what you mean by that
then let's say
if if you're taking care of your parents
because they're
ill that's not the example that I use
though what's your example the guy that
lives at home that's not getting out on
his own two feet and you know showing
the drive and ambition that women are
looking
for yeah I mean that's not what I'm
looking for is that what you're running
into a lot of guys do have that going
for them yes okay but that's not a turn
on for you no okay so we can call that a
turn off we can call that not a good
thing yes okay all right
so coming back to what you're dealing
with sorry to interrupt and sort of
Sidetrack on that it's just I that
that's one of the things Mo that sort of
grinds my gears is like when we have
this you know have these conversations
with the gals and it's like let's just
let's just be honest about it and say
guys get your [__] together stop living
at home mooching off your parents you
know become something become competent
become captivating go do something with
your life go out there and put a dent in
your Universe like go out there and be a
force of Awesomeness
right just wanted to call that out
because it's one of the things that
grinds my gears because gals are afraid
to say those things go make some serious
money um you want somebody on your level
so Define what your level is so what
kind of guy are you looking for like if
you could create this Avatar of you know
the Mis version that you're
after um do you mean physical or mental
or both give me it all
um so obviously I want someone who's
driven um I personally myself I want to
make as much money as possible I want to
be a boss woman I want to do everything
there is to do I want to see the world
all that great stuff um I want to be fit
and I want to be hot and I the guy that
I'm looking for I want to be driven I'm
I enjoy people who out because I work
out a
ton um most of the time I'm usually at
the gym right now so I love the gym it's
my outlet to get out all my stress from
work
[Music]
um other than that what kind of physique
does he have to have like a muscular
physique a swimmer's body like what are
you looking
for I like guys who are like super
muscular okay so you like a muscular
dude how
tall um as long as you're taller than me
that's fine 5 five okay so that's pretty
easy so goty 56 or
higher okay are you writing it all down
well I'm making some notes Here Yeah
okay and you know like as far as his
character you know what he does for a
living um I don't really like anything
in particular that I'm looking for as
far as like in a career I just want I
feel that at at our point in our lives
like with with our age you should be in
a career not a job not you know working
as a bagger at Giant or something like
that you should be you should have a
career and know what you want to
do with your life so what's a career uh
like a service adviser at an automotive
dealership and
hire um a career would be
I think I think anything that you are
super passionate about that you can
climb the ladder and you have a set goal
like for instance in my case I want to
be a general manager of a dealership I
want to own a dealership one day that's
my goal but I have to start somewhere
and work my way up and I have worked my
butt off to get to where I
am um and I want that same thing for the
person that I'm looking for
okay so like what what kind of guys
you've been attracted to in the past
while you're dating like what do they do
for a living like what sort of careers
they
have
um so my ex was in the
military that was fine um he worked very
hard um and you know like all of his PT
tests he passed them all with like
flying colors great for him
um other than that
um I have I have been with
uh some guys that just weren't On My
Level I like I can't
even like one of my exes still lived
with his mom and just like smoked weed
in her basement and that was just he
didn't even have a
job um like I've been with guys who were
like electricians plumbers
like you name it I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out